-Welcome back, everybody.
We're here with Alicia Keys!
-Hey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You've done so many things,
so many cool things.
By the way, I can't wait
to talk about this
because this is
just the raddest.
It's awesome.
Yeah, I know, it's so fun.
15 Grammys, best-selling author,
but also, you're into the --
in fashion, as well, Athleta.
-Yes.
-Yeah, talk to me about this.
-So Athleta I love because
I'm actually a fan of Athleta
as a mom, as a person who likes
to work out, likes to meditate,
just be able to have that
kind of soft, sweet energy.
But what I love about them
the most
is that they're all about
body consciousness
and body positivity
and body diversity.
And so we created
a limited-edition collection
that we're doing together.
And it goes from all the way up
to 3X in size,
which I think is so important
to be able to find yourself
in the store.
-Yeah.
-And it's all about
powerful colors and boldness
and really empowering women
to feel incredible
so that you can throw on
your little fit, go to the gym,
take your kids to school,
go take a brunch,
and still be fresh and powerful
the whole time.
-Wait till you see it.
It looks so cool.
I'm like, "Oh, how do you --"
I mean, it's awesome.
Go to athleta.com and check out
Alicia Keys, what you did.
And then can we just
talk about this?
This is so cool,
and I just told you this.
I had the book because
I knew you were coming on.
I went to the bookstore
this weekend.
Shout-out to BookHampton.
They had a big, big display
of your book.
-BookHampton!
-It looked great.
It was awesome.
And I was like --
It just -- And it popped out,
and I was there with my girls.
And I'm like, this is great,
what you're doing.
-I love this.
This is a graphic novel.
It's my first graphic novel.
I love it so much.
I think it's a beautiful way
to introduce kids
to just continue to fall in love
with words and reading,
and I've been so grateful to
have fallen in love with words.
And that's why I'm a songwriter
and why I'm a storyteller,
because I love words.
So when you meet Lolo --
Her name is Lolo.
She's from Brooklyn.
She's raised by a single father,
who's also raising her brother.
Her mother is actually
not around.
As you read the story,
you'll find out why.
And her brother
was racially profiled
and attacked
by a police officer,
and she got so upset,
she wanted to protect him,
and she just didn't know
what to do,
and she realizes at that moment
that she has
these special powers,
this kinetic energy that could
actually hurt you very badly.
And she's trying to figure out,
"What do I do with this energy?
How do I harness it?
How do I use it?
Am I crazy?"
And the whole book
is really a metaphor
to the superpowers we all have
and trying to find our way
to harness it.
-Wait till you see the reaction
you're going to get
from teenagers and kids
and parents reading it.
Watching a kid read your stuff,
it's like --
-It's crazy.
-It's game-changing.
You go, "Wow, we're so lucky to
be able to do stuff like this."
But good on you for doing this.
-And the song "Girl on Fire" has
been such a powerful statement,
and I wrote it
when I didn't feel on fire.
I wrote it when I felt like
I couldn't make it,
when I saw my friends
and my family members, as women,
feeling defeated,
and reminding us
that there is nothing that
stops us, we are on fire.
And so to see this transform
into a book
that can hopefully do that
for so many others is like --
I'm super grateful.
-That's what I'm talking about.
That is Alicia Keys.
Thank you so much
for being here in person.
I missed you!
I missed you, bud.
Congrats on everything.
Alicia Keys, everybody.
"Girl on Fire" is out now.